hi my name is Jesse Friedman my talk is
retro printing using a pen plotter with
the Wolfram language pen plotters are in
rather older computer physical computer
output device instead of using pixels
and rows and columns like a raster
printer they move a physical pen around
on paper to draw so they're very fun to
control and they integrate pretty well
with the Wolfram language is symbolic
graphics capability
now I was planning to have this whole
thing about explaining what a pen
plotter is but a lot of the people I've
met here know that already so but that
this is just a brief overview pen
plotters are one of the earliest
physical output devices for computers
and as the name may suggest they work by
moving a pen around on paper so instead
of dealing in terms of rows columns and
pixels like a raster printer they deal
in terms of points and lines and circles
now this particular pen plotter the HP
7550 a has an eight pen carousel which
means that you can have eight pens of up
to eight different colors and you can
switch between them during your white
while you're plotting so before the
introduction of the inkjet printer pen
plotters were actually the most
efficient and really the only viable
solution for high resolution color
graphic graphics output and as as my
title may suggest retro printing these
are a little bit out of out of style now
one might say but I find them fun to
work with because they're relatively
easy to control compared to like a
postscript
raster printer or something and the
output quality is really quite good and
as I mentioned this is the HP 75 50 it's
the fastest desktop pen plotter ever
produced there are faster ones that are
for big for making like big like
architectural drawings and stuff but
this was the fastest one that can fit on
your desk just barely and it has another
nice features the auto feed paper tray a
lot of pen plotters did not have this so
it has like like a regular printer that
you might have at home it has a paper
tray and it can automatically suck up
paper and and put it on the on the
writing surface and it's controlled over
serial rs-232 with HP GL which is HP's
old vector graphics description language
which is as I mentioned is fairly easy
to to generate and it was introduced in
1984 and sold for thirty nine hundred
dollars that's nineteen eighty four
dollars so
I have not done the conversion to figure
out how much that's worth now but it was
pretty pricey but now you can get them
for under $100 on eBay which is where I
got mine
so why integrate an outdated device with
Wolfram language as I mentioned HP GL is
very easy to to understand and to
generate and it and since it's a vector
graphics description language it pairs
up pretty well with the Wolfram language
as symbolic graphics and it's fun I mean
these people from 1980 whatever seem to
be having a pretty good time okay so a
quick demo of HP GL link the Wolfram
language package I wrote that converts
Wolfram language symbolic graphics
directives and primitives into HP geo
so I'll load that and then there's so I
have a kind of weird setup for
controlling the plotter you I would have
used woven language device connect
serial just to control it directly from
my laptop over serial but it uses a a
flow control system that from from my
attempts to to implement it it doesn't
seem to really be compatible with with
Wolfram language serial so what I'm
actually doing I have a Raspberry Pi in
that giant desk that is commute that is
directly connected to the plotter over
serial and then I'm using WebSocket or
no actually for this I'm using just at
HTTP and it's running an HTTP server and
it's accepting HP GL strings and it just
sends that over serial using the proper
flow control but yeah I can print this
or I can generate this first and you'll
see that the HP GL graphics function it
returns a graphics proper graphics
object and you you use just regular
graphics directives and primitives to
control it but when I when I use to
string on it it become magically becomes
the HP GL text the the commands that are
sent over serial to the plotter and then
when I if I use print it's print HP GL
graphics that will
and be sent to the Raspberry Pi and if
all goes well it starts printing it so
this is just a simple demo thing you'll
notice the colors in this graphics
object these are specified by these
these pen directives here and that's
just saying use the pen with index seven
in the eight pen carousel and the colors
are sort of chosen arbitrarily so
they're unique across pens but it
doesn't actually represent what's going
to appear on that paper and I'm using
fill type four which is on this pen
plotter it's a cross-hatched fill type
so it's a lot faster to draw then then
actually filling in a solid fill so
that's it's doing a circle now and then
it's gonna do I think another circle or
another disk and then a dashed line and
then it will be done so my my my plan
here is while while this is printing or
while I've two other printing examples
but while this is printing I can answer
any questions which I think it's just
about to be done actually Oh circle and
dashed line that's my favorite part the
- no no actually this is my favorite
part I assume these these were sold with
some kind of paper cash tray but mine
did not come with any so I am the paper
catch tray and this is what what this
output looks like it's graphics thank
you thank you thank you very much
okay so now on to doing more interesting
stuff with it now you may be familiar
with Wolfram language or Wolfram Alpha
is popular curbs feature which is a
database a database of hundreds of
parametric curves that are designed
manually or semi automatically sculpted
to match the facial features of like
famous people and famous characters so
since this is the Wolfram technology
conference I think we should use our
famous character Stephen Wolfram so
about okay actually I have to go onto my
onto the
proper internet thing because if this is
connected to a router that's in there
which isn't on the internet because it
needs to get to the Raspberry Pi but
anyways well when I do this I should get
within a reasonable amount of time okay
that's just that's just the entity
representing the Stephen Wolfram curve
and let's go back on he oh wait now I
actually need to stay there until I get
the mesh representation it would be it
would be nicer if I could do this over a
serial but direct serial from the
computer so yet this is a this is a
Wolfram language mesh region that's just
generated from that curve I assume
they're just sampling along it's using
some kind of algorithm to this to decide
how to sample along that that parametric
curb and then I'll switch back to my
network but I can get the mesh
coordinates of connected mesh components
it gives you a list of the individual
connected or closed curves that are part
of that mesh and then mesh coordinates
is just the coordinates of each point
along there and then I'm resampling it
because there are a whole lot of points
and I don't need I don't need all of
them now I'm using just line mapping
across that to generate one of my
special HP GL graphics objects and pen
number six is a is a red ballpoint pen
it's my favorite and orientation
portrait you could also test my
landscape landscape is the default for
HP GL graphics and what it does is
unless you specify a plot range it will
automatically scale your graphics up so
it fills the paper so I have that and
then I can you can see if I do to string
it's a fair bit more complicated than
that sample thing from earlier but these
are these from LT to LT or actually from
pen down to pen up those are each of the
individual curbs and now I can use that
print HB GL graphics graphic and that
will start drawing Stephen Wolfram and
as I mentioned I can take some questions
during this period of art
yeah you can get the they were sold in
in like vacuum sealed bags so you can
still get the original pens and there
are also companies that made like sort
of clones of those and I think I
couldn't actually find any that are that
are verifiably still in production but I
think companies still may actually make
the pens for this bladder the ballpoint
pen is an original HP pen it I mean it
came in like a maybe not vacuum sealed
but a sealed enclosure so so I didn't
have to worry about it
drying out here this is stephen wolfram
yeah so yes you can still get the
original paddies okay so I'm gonna move
on to the next thing
so unfortunately not everyone is lucky
enough to have a popular curve in
WolframAlpha over their face so if you
have been in the dark recess recessed
corner of the downstairs area you may
have seen my pen plotter photo booth so
since not everyone has a curve of their
face in fact I think Stephen Wolfram is
probably the only person in this
building who has one and WolframAlpha
but I have a an image vectorization
system and I'll just walk through this
this is a picture of can you guess can
anyone guess who this is I don't know
who no I know that that's my
doppelganger okay so yeah that image I
just took that that downstairs a couple
hours ago so edge detect may be familiar
with edge detect it it returns an image
of here the binary image like this where
all the white pixels represent the edges
of in the image he didn't looks like it
didn't get my hair very well and then
I'm using this the second argument to
edge detect to just specify this sort of
specify the threshold aside actually I
think it's the radius but anyway it's to
decide on the edges and then thinning
just to get at all of the edges down to
one pixel wide and then this so this
returns an image now i can use image
value
to get all the the coordinates of all of
the white pixels the pixels of value one
so that's just going to give me a fairly
fairly large array two-dimensional so
it's just an array it doesn't doesn't
take into account rows and columns it
just the XY coordinates of all of those
white pixels then I'm down sampling that
like before because I don't want all of
them I just want to sort of interpolate
between them I don't want the pen
plotter to interpolate between them and
then the floor just because it does this
weird thing where the it gives you the
center of the pixel which is like one
twenty point five so I floor that down
to an integer that I'm defining to
setting that to a variable point so you
can see it's just an array of
coordinates and then this is the this is
the secret sauce there's a cool function
called find curve path which breaks up
that array of coordinates into a set of
discrete curves so the I'll show you
actually the raw output from that which
is in array of arrays or an array of
arrays of indexes in that points that
points list and then I'm pulling out
those the values of those indexes values
at those indexes or indices and the
mapping line across that to get a set of
line line directives so find curved
paths is cool because it means that I
don't have to do a continuous like a
continuous line I can pick up the pan
and move somewhere else so of that and
then as before HP Geographics using that
so a spitting image of of me okay and
then I can like before there print HP GL
graphics of I should have put that in a
variable but and then it's going to do
same thing as before
again any any questions I can take
during this period
yep you
and I define the make boxes for I'll for
two-string I'll I'll show you the code
after after this official slideshow is
done and Chris did you have
okay yes sure so I think this is almost
done so is it okay anyways
so what's running on there is a Python
server that's that's taking HTTP
requests and then it yeah we just take
this okay that's that's me so it's a
Python server that's taking HTTP
requests and then sending them over
serial the reason it's Python instead of
just raw wool from language is that I
also use the same server for my photo
booth think my photo booth thing where
it does the vectorization and the
processing on the PI so then it's been
it's calling a Wolfram script so
invoking Wolfram language externally if
I had known about the new socket connect
and the duplex persistent TCP sockets
and Wolfram language I probably would
have done the whole thing in Wolfram
language but I didn't at the time and I
definitely wish I had done it in
something that's not Python but because
python is very bad at asynchronous stuff
which is exactly what I'm trying to do
here but yeah as I said I'll go into the
the code for the package after this and
you can see what that's doing and I
think this is my last slide okay
Oh any questions is a cool resource is
the HP computer museum which they have
they have scans of not only the the
100-something page operation manual and
the 400-something page programming
manual for this plotter but they also
have the original service manual so that
details everything if anything goes
wrong it tells you what to do to fix it
and I definitely would not have a
working platter here if not for the
service manual and so I guess thanks to
HP for making a service manual which you
don't really see anymore these days but
and also for the HP computer museum for
hosting those those files and any
questions other than what the package
looks like anything okay well yeah let's
see what the package looks like
unfortunately I don't think I can
magnify this so you'll just have to
squint so yeah I am
so yeah I'm defining
put form for the to string bit and
that's its that that's the that's the
big part the and then for the the
graphics part that's somewhere up here
it's these make boxes so I'm I'm
outputting when you put it in the
Wolfram language front end you get a
graphics box or a set of graphics boxes
as you're like visual result but it
still has all that HP GL or the all the
vector data inside it okay
any other questions okay
yeah oh yeah print here this is what
that looks like since I have the server
on the I print HP GL graphics is just
posting that HP GL data to the server
running on the PI and if I were using
device connect I would just be using
like device right or device right buffer
to write that string directly over
serial but I'm not so this is what it
looks like and then it's doing this CV
thing is cool which it basically tells
it to to buffer up commands for a little
bit and within a line it does a little
bit of like curb smoothing so the lines
end up a little better and then AF is
auto feed it just tells it to spit the
paper out and suck in another sheet for
the next next run okay anything else
nope going going gone thank you